welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul and we're in the end zone
now with a super bowl trailer for doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
throughout this video we're going to be
going over all the hidden details in it
teaching you right from wong and also
discussing our theories on who could be
showing up i think that the first
trailer released at the end of nowhere
home also fills in a lot of the plot too
so we'll be going over that and talking
about how it teases what's in this one
if you enjoyed the video then please
smash the thumbs up button and also
don't forget to subscribe for videos
like this every day without the way
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into the multiverse of madness
okay so when we last saw steven strange
he was the doctor making you forget
rather than being the doctor you forgot
about what
if you look at things from his
perspective he has no idea why the
multiverse is cracked open as he now no
longer remembers
someone someone from that movie now this
is why he's gone to wonder who after the
events of west view has been lying alone
near what may or may not be wonderful
mountain in the first trailer we got a
good look at our garden in which it
seemed like she'd planted hundreds and
hundreds of white trees going off on a
big symbolism tangent these in many ways
represent the multiple worlds that we
will be visiting in the movie they're
all very similar looking but if you get
up close you'll notice minor differences
to them adding to this metaphor strange
first comes across wonder pruning
branches which is terminology that was
used in loki when the tva talked about
shutting down offshoots of a timeline
the color white typically represents
peace and in spiritualism it's classed
as being something that shows acceptance
the opposite to this is red which is
embodied within wonders red chaos magic
now my guess is that initially wonder
will be at peace with losing her
children but after she learns variants
of them exist within the multiverse that
she'll attempt to go after them this
trailer confirms that wanda will be one
of the villains and in the first teaser
we got a hint towards this when wong was
being held up by glowing red magic i
actually think that she might be the
main antagonist in the movie but there
are other ones that could be popping up
we of course also have the multiple
doctor strangers and also baron mordo
who we'll talk about later on in the
video now if the darker version is
indeed the same one from what if then he
in many ways will be a mirror of wonder
as the pair both lost the person that
they loved they tried whatever they
could to bring them back including
completely warping reality and there's a
lot of great things that they can do
here with both of them wander is
somewhat a troubled character in the
comics and throughout the graphic novel
house of m she completely reorganized
reality just to get her heart's desires
this created a dilemma for the x-men and
avengers who had to decide whether she
was too dangerous to be left alive in
the end it culminated with her uttering
the phrase no more mutants which could
be flipped on its head for this film so
that she creates them now at one point
in the teaser we get her discussing how
she's seen as a villain for breaking
reality whereas strange does it and he's
lauded as a hero
you break the rules look out
and become a hero
i do it i become the enemy
during this section we also see several
versions of wonder including one where
she fights a mysterious person covered
in a golden light
the theories online are that this is
actually captain marvel and that
definitely makes sense however i
actually think that this might be monica
rambo who in this reality could be
captain marvel in the comics she did
take on the moniker and with her getting
introduced in one division it would be
great to see the pair going head to head
now she might be part of a council
that's featured later on but there's
multiple versions of wonder and it's
going to be really interesting to see
what they do with her at one point she
can be seen looking over a version of
herself as the skull at witch in west
view which is in the same house that she
built in one division if you recall the
show this was actually something that
didn't exist in reality and it was the
location that vision wanted to create
for the pear to grow old in it seems
like this might be a reality where she
got to live in it which links back to
our theory from earlier that she's
trying to get someone else's kids hide
your wife hide your vis hide your kids
now one version is passionate towards
the other whilst the other one seems to
be defeated and we later see a vision
that's covered in blood likely having
massacred someone there's also a zombie
version of her looking really scary
likely about to suck the life force out
of a character there's a lot going on
and this idea of multiples is shown
early on when the trailer opens with
strange discussing his dreams the idea
of eyes is given a lot of focus as we
zoom in on our only wonders but we also
open with a close-up of strange when he
talks about them i love this idea that
the nightmare is reality and not the
dream itself and hey it's a nice bit of
dialogue he says that every night he
dreams the same dream and we get a
destroyed version of the sanctum where
that's all that remains in a certain
reality
every night
i dream the same dream
the nightmare begins is that a face is
that who no no no no that can't be
now this sanctorum shot is something
that we saw the opposite side of in the
first trailer you can pretty much
confirm from the water running along the
floor that this is a setup to the shot
just before he meets the evil supreme
strange these dreams strange hairs are
obviously not dreams and they're in fact
glimpses into the minds of its variants
across the multiverse they're somewhat
connected on a psychic level and perhaps
his deaths are what triggers him to wake
up at night in these glimpses we can
catch a giant red ribbon like monster
and also america chevez just as she's
about to get ripped apart you can see a
portal open behind her in the shape of a
star which is how she travels across
into other dimensions in the comics my
guess is that just before she gets
killed she travels through this and into
the mcu also judging by the pillar in
the scene this is somewhere that strange
christine in america travel to at one
point now as for america's chavez she's
actually not from the mcu and has come
across from another reality she's
something that we know frighteningly
little about but i do like her denim
valen denim now as for her powers and
abilities america can open multiversal
portals so that she can travel across
universes she also has super strength
invulnerability and she's one of the
most powerful characters in marvel
comics she debuted inventions issue 1 as
part of the team brigade fighting
against the young masters of evil now
she was meant to appear in spider-man
now at home but this was cut out due to
the rescheduling in which the release
order was switched so that that movie
came out first we now have concept art
from the film that shows america was
going to be the one that brought toby
and andrew across but this was switched
to ned who's now a wizard or something
anyway america was also meant to appear
at the statue of liberty at the end of
the movie and it is possible that she
was the one who sent the villains and
heroes back to their realities
originally america and her two mothers
lived on a utopian parallel outside of
the multiverse which may have appeared
in the first teaser at the risk of
collapse her mother saved the reality
but upon pulling it into the main
universe they died leading america to
run away through this she would find the
616 reality and become the hero that we
know today however as of 2021 she was
given a brand new origin story in the
america chavez mad in the usa comic
issue 3. in reality the original origin
was something that she made up as her
mothers were from earth and they took
her and her sister to a billionaire
called mr gayle she and her sister had
something called edges syndrome which
gail wanted to heal and against their
parents judgements they let him help her
mothers would die helping the girls
escape girls island when it was revealed
that he exploited them after the events
of vengeance she would then join the
young avengers and fight off an
interdimensional parasite which
showcased her multiversal powers she
will later team up with the ultimates of
earth 616 not the edgy ones and help
captain america and co on some of the
most mind-bending cosmic adventures her
powers and multiversal knowledge will be
the key to helping dr strange traverse
the fractured realities and she's
definitely going to be one of the most
important characters in the movie now
the marvel studios logo being used for
the film differs slightly from the
standardized one in the mcu in the first
teaser we got the fox and sony versions
and in this trailer we get the x-men
come across in the form of professor rex
there's also what appears to be the what
if logo and we do see destroy new york
much in the same way that it was in the
show i think the marvel studios logo on
this one does look very similar to how
it did in the series possibly hinting at
characters from that coming across now
professor x will once more be played by
patrick stewart and he seems to be part
of a council in another reality judging
by the ultron bots to take him in i'm
guessing that this is one where the
machine worked and it created a suit of
armor around the world the whole play
seems prosperous but there's also an
undertone of an almost authoritarian
state due to the statues we see they're
very similar the hammering sickle giving
us the idea that there's something going
on here that we aren't privy to this
scene was actually filmed in a uk museum
and shout out to chatterbox films for
sending that through we know that the
film was delayed and during this time
there were extensive reshoots which are
rumored to have brought across several
actors who will appear in cameo roles
john krasinski was trending a couple of
weeks ago with fans asking that he
finally plays reed richards and this
would be an awesome way to introduce
marvel's first family when the movie was
first announced it was reported that the
illuminati would be appearing in the
film and if you look at the comics this
was made up of several characters
including strange reed and professor x
how that we get some beyond that
including a live-action version of
captain carter from what if and also the
true quick silver after they ralph bone
at us having aaron taylor johnson shot
would also be big too as there has to be
a version of him out there in the
multiverse there's really a lot of
things that could happen with the movie
and just in the same way that no way
home kept us guessing i think that this
film will too now a huge thank you to
impractical tv for also pointing out
that you can catch captain carter's
shield in the poster so she may be part
of the council as well i think that
defender strange will have been a part
of this too and he might have died in
this reality which is why there are
statues for him seeing a character who
they think has died coming in would of
course arouse suspicion and this might
be why they bring him before the council
now in the initial trailer we
encountered two new versions of doctor
strange this included the darker more
sinister one and defender strange who we
could see falling through a star-shaped
portal two weeks ago a poster released
with the pair on it alongside the mcu
version i think that no defender strange
seems like a good one he'll also be evil
or well at least disagree with the mcu
one symbolically i think that he
represents order taken to an extreme or
as the darker one is the opposite of
this and a complete embodiment of chaos
this is why the sanctuarium is
completely messed up and hurtling
through an endless void that looks like
ryan aries mum's vagina now strange
somewhat lies in the middle of the pair
as he's not completely chaotic but he's
also not reigning enough to not cast for
getting spells just to make people stop
remembering
remembering who
who was again anyway whether the darker
version is from what if remains to be
seen but this one is likely heavily
along the same lines we know from the
trailer that christine palmer will be
getting married to someone other than
stephen and much in the same way that
the what-if version lost her stephen
could have to come to terms with this
too she's not dead though mate yeah move
on now in the first trailer we could
actually catch you joining steven in
america chavez so it does seem like she
will be going with them into the
multiverse i think defender strange will
very much just be a souped up variant
who wants to bring order to everything
and through him we'll see how this is
just as bad as chaos if you cast your
mind back to the first trailer you'll
remember that mordo talked about how
strange was the greatest threat to their
universe
i'm sorry stephen
i hope you understand
the greatest threat
to our universe
is you
whilst it was implied that this was the
strange supreme one it could actually be
the defender one two in the graphic
novel age of ultron we came across an
alternate version of strange called dun
dun dun defender strange now we
discovered that he was from an alternate
universe in which hank pym had been
killed by a time traveling wolverine so
that he couldn't create ultron look it
was a big long-winded thing now this led
to an offshoot reality which was
somewhat a fascist state that could be
embodied by defender strange everything
came to a head when the witch morgan
lafayette attacked which could be
mirrored and wonder who also possesses
most of her abilities morgan messed up
the entire reality and destroyed it just
as wolverine escaped which is something
that wonder could end up doing and
that's why we see karmatage being
attacked i also feel that the mortar
we've seen in the teasers is actually a
variant of the character and it not the
one from the mcu i think this would be a
great twist on things and we know from
the toys that he'll be called master
moto instead of baron which may or may
not be hinting towards this now we do
see mordo as part of the council so i
think this variant theory is pretty much
confirmed professor x coming back is
obviously the biggest part of the
trailer for me and since no way home we
know that anything is possible we do get
a character from the comics in rintar
and he's a wizard as well possibly from
another dimension or the mcu one he's
basically a giant minotaur and i can't
believe i'm saying this but he might be
the least interesting thing about this
internet breaking teaser it's that good
even minor tours you're like uh just a
minor tour now there's also the wizard
from the first movie that strange
initially thought was the sorcerer
supreme and it looks like they're
bringing everyone back they're bringing
everyone back now at one point we also
see america and strange tumbling through
realities this includes one where
dinosaurs still exist and it's such a
cool background detail there's also a
moment where their forms turn into
squares as well which was something that
thanos did to drax in infinity war when
changing reality now we know that
gargantos will be attacking new york
earlier in the movie and this is where
strange will meet america in case you
don't know the giant creature is
actually a name or villain but i think
for this movie they've changed it up so
that he comes from another dimension
instead of the ocean giant squids were
teased throughout what if and whilst it
was initially thought to be schumer
gorath they may have altered things to
make a gargantos instead the teaser has
a shot of wong fighting it and i expect
this goes down early on the trailer ends
with lots of action including a zombie
version of strange which i'm guessing
could be the what if one fully powered
up judging by the shadow entities that
seem to be surrounding him he's tapped
into the dark hold and is about to
destroy everything it's a really cool
shot to end on that yeah makes this
movie look crazy and i'm going to talk
about my thoughts on it in just a bit
[Music]
[Applause]
now as for my thoughts on the trailer i
think since spider-man know a home that
the marketing for these movies has
changed quite a lot and that marvel will
be keeping a lot of the big reveals in
it pretty close to the best i've heard a
lot of leaks on the film that i don't
want to go too deep into on a trailer
breakdown but the movie sounds like it's
going to be packed with cameos and lots
of major characters turning up just like
no way home that was such a big movie in
terms of what it did for the genre and i
think that this will knock it out of the
park there's so many directions that
they can take it and it's got such a
dark tone to it that it looks absolutely
gripping this seems like it's going to
be unlike any other mcu movie that's
come before and it's important on a
number of levels as it sets up one of
the big heroes as a villain whilst also
bridging the gap between the fox
franchise dizzy spent a lot of money
buying the company just to do a boner
joke and it's about time they used some
of the characters which i can't wait to
see really really excited for it and
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
below we are in competition right now
and giving away three copies of the june
box set on the 28th of feb and all you
have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on we pick
the comments at random at the end of the
month and the winners of the last one on
screen right now so if that's you then
message me on twitter at heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check our breakdown of the
book of boba fett finale which will be
linked on screen right now we went over
the full final episode talking about all
the easter eggs in it and it's
definitely worth checking out right
after this without the way thanks for
sticking through the video i've been
paul to see in the next one take care
peace